e aí
a se filiarem a história não encontram
nenhum momento com tantos problemas em
cima da mesa do mundo
eu nunca foi tão necessário parar para
pensar como o ju eu estou aqui
simplesmente para agitar as águas do mar
em que caímos
e dane-se
é a vida o milagre da vida ocorreu há 4
bilhões de anos
e nos seres humanos surgimos aqui a
apenas 200 mil anos
e no entanto conseguimos quebrar o
equilíbrio que é tão essencial à vida na
terra
e é urgente pensar ascenso a
sustentabilidade ea sustentabilidade
começa por nós precisamos de parar para
pensar e voltar para dentro
a refletir acalmar o stress em que
vivemos
é porque esses tentabilidade a
verdadeira sustentabilidade acontece a
partir de nós
e tudo o resto virá por acréscimo
se repararem nós vivemos muito a partir
daquilo que recebemos da comunicação
social e hoje vivemos numa autêntica
babel não são apenas os jornais que hoje
poucos leem
e não são apenas as televisões e rádios
os festivais todos os polos que divulgam
cultura ou comunicam
é mas toda esta pangeia virtual em que
caímos estamos a perder o pé estamos a
viver na cloud já repararam a barra
funda em que estamos metidos
e já pensaram no horizonte onde se pode
levar-nos
ah pois não são apenas as notícias que
muitas vezes são falsas e cada vez mais
falsas
e é confusão que existe no seio familiar
por exemplo os conflitos e as guerras a
mortandade dos assassínios
e não é possível
a humanidade só se encontra quando
voltar ao valor do amor isso é a grande
fonte da sustentabilidade
o pastor pararmos e este carlos um pouco
mais a nossa leitura sobre aquilo que
nos rodeia
e os negócios hoje são escuros e cada
vez mais escuros a política a banca
e a própria saúde não gritante em
portugal mas no mundo em geral por quero
falar para o mundo anda muito mal é um
bem público é o grande bem sustenta a
vida nós temos que olhar para isto
e tem que chegar a todos
e este valor
e a corrupção campeia a falta da
morosidade falta de fim conhecidad falta
de articulação das partes para que o bem
comum bem maior seja samba guardado e
com isso tudo nós estamos a caminho
e da falência do sistema temos que parar
para pensar
um exemplo verdadeiramente pode cantar
vitória no meio disto tudo e tecnologia
não vou falar contra ela nem um pouco
mais ou menos ela indica em cima
é mas temos que a por ao nosso serviço
não podemos viver na paz rei virtual
completamente em silvalde aos telemóveis
aos computadores e periféricos há tempo
para tudo na terra tempo para nascer e
tempo para viver e tempo para morrer é
sentido mais lá e temos que dar um tempo
para cada coisa
e como é que nós podemos sair visto
desde logo criando uma espécie de globo
academy
é um ensino diferente começa com as
crianças e cria grandes pensadores
depois nas universidades politécnico de
outros institutos de ensino uma nova
pedagogia uma pedagogia diferente que
nos leva a ter grandes
os condutores da comunidade humana
eu nunca mais mente capuz na cadeira do
poder nunca mais
e não é só pela ditadura que eles possam
circular é para os malefícios quase
eternos que eles podem semear na
sociedade
a educação dizia o nosso querido nelson
mandela
e é melhor arma para mudar o mundo
nós vamos fazer isso
e aí
e a globalização trouxe nos
e muitas coisas boas
o dobro fronteiras falamos todos os
outros sem tempo praticamente real
muitas vezes real
é mas
um dos outros conceitos e é o da casa
comum vamos são próximo nunca tivemos
tanta
e nos faltamos uma casa para o encontro
das culturas
só falta nos uma casa para o rival da
partilha
e eu proponho que ela exista em algum
lugar do mundo portugal
esse é um país de eleição para esse
efeito mas se não acontecer seja onde
for o mundo é pequeno o nosso pequeno
como localização
o que proponho é a réplica daquilo que é
a terra propriamente uma cúpula
e devidamente construída ecologicamente
os próximos consequências e coerentes
com aquilo que dizemos é sabor as falhas
do nosso tempo é não haver alinhamento
com pensamos dizemos e fazemos lá
alinhamento é preciso construir estes
nessa casa
bom senso pode ter a configuração do
hemisfério norte
o acento sobre uma uma folha
o gigante
e aí para nos fazer lembrar que jamais
podemos fazer incursões malucas seja por
um flor sem pensar no equilíbrio da
natureza que é fome
o rapaz decisão
é nesse lugar eu proponho que haja um
grande ecrã
o quanto é que o vigia de gases a
reproduzir o mapa do mundo
eu ia botar aí apob100 para o palco e
ficar em algum ponto
e tendo como resposta
e do outro lado no serengeti o alasca o
eva
é uma equipa de cientistas responde aos
nossos anseios as questões vamos colocar
plantas estudar nos a noção de família
os fornos em interagir
uma coisa que uma posição nos deu
e a programação de cada dia deste a que
chamam santuário da consciência global
e eu proponho que
e o país faça umas anos nesse dia esteja
presente e de contas ao mundo daquilo
que anda a fazer para o bem-estar da
comunidade global
e no dia dez de junho portugal será
chamado com seu presidente da república
primeiro-ministro ministro do ambiente
todos aqueles que como é que é o menos
por importantes para o diálogo para a
seleção são chamados ali para dar contas
à comunidade internacional do que anda a
fazer para o bem comum isto é
simplesmente maravilhoso e aí vamos
poder fazer outra coisa linda parte do
movimento que criei há uns quatro anos
depois do desafio de uma universidade
portuguesa
e vamos poder certificados próprios
países em função daquilo que andam a
fazer o bem
o movimento colher chama-se love in the
player
e é lindo
eu nunca mais consegui parar de olhar
para ele buscar a minha consciência
naquilo
é mas preciso do vosso envolvimento
preciso do vosso engate mano do vasco
por isso comigo também
e nós precisamos urgentemente de ter um
caso de amor com a vida e é possível por
este caminho
o livro que me acompanha sempre a este
tem atravessado gerações têm
sensibilizado
há milhões de pessoas no mundo
e o seu autor o santa cruz do pery hoje
na boca do principezinho
a estas palavras são a mensagem eterna
e o essencial é invisível aos olhos
é por amor de deus pense nisto deixem o
rebanho em foco em cada um esse
e eu tenho certeza que se saída
oi para o mundo melhor está em cada um
de nós
o tanto agora diretamente para cada um
deixa o orgulho tu és o caminho não é
possível chegar a felicidade global
e foi na assunção destes valores
bom obrigado tá